Kirk, you hungry?
Yeah, I could totally use
some salad.
[blabbering]
- Good to see this new
generation of drunk shamers
being more calorie conscious.
Kirk, you hungry?
Yeah, I could totally use
some salad.
[blabbering]
- That's not a salad
until one of those guys blows
a hot load of ranch on him.
Shocking that a stay
at home mom
found time
in her grueling schedule
to set this up.
Is part of this prank.
living in that narrow wood
paneled popcorn
ceiling hellhole?
She left the door ajar
so he'll actually
come home excited
thinking his family
was murdered.
Classic! Epic pownage.
This is the single saddest
moment silly string
has ever been involved in.
He's not mad, he's just
disappointed with his entire
life.
If you find yourself getting
scratchers
and Vitamin Water
at the Kwik Fill in Syracuse,
be on the lookout.
Hey, Josh, look at this
huge moth that I found.
Get that [bleep] out of here.
Oh, there it goes.
You [bleep].
Isn't that cool?
Yeah, that's cool.
Get it out of here, man.
100% chance that moth
ends up on the hot dog rollers.
It's never too late
to let someone know
how you feel about them.
[Indistinct chatter]
Man: Come here.
I just want you to know
how much I love you.
I got one question for you.
[ Velcro rips ]
Oh, my God!
Oh, you were so close to being
out of that relationship.
[ Laughter ]
[ Crying ]
Will you marry me?
Yes, I will.
Every girl's fantasy --
a prank-posal.
Who's ready
for the Prank of the Week?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking
foreign language ]
[ Laughs ]
[ Audience groaning ]
[ Gagging ]
And the war between North
and South Korea is back on!
You really want
to freak her out?
Do it with
a mouth full of Nesquik.
[ Laughs ]
Eh, she won't be
the last girl tricked into
drinking man milk
against her will.
#MeTwoPercent.